so the first time most recently that I
remember being starstruck was I was
doing the Hollywood roundtable for
actresses and I knew that Oprah was
gonna be there and she's one of the
people that I have looked up to and
watched I mean she was basically a
reference point growing up cuz like you
know if you're having an argument about
facts my friends would be like no that's
not true how do you know and I'd be like
Oprah Winfrey said and you know and that
was the way we knew that and then that
was the end of the discussion so anyway
I know I'm good to meet Oprah I've
meditated all morning getting prepared
for this and then I'm at the shoot I'm
sitting by my makeup station and my hair
stylist head looks through the mirror
and says and I get up and it's like slow
motion I turn around and Oprah Winfrey
is coming towards me and our arms open
wide and she gives me this big hug and
she says you were amazing in that movie
and it was just like home and she
separates it from me and all I could get
up was hi Oprah and that was all I could
say and then she walked away and I sat
down at my station and pulled out a
notebook and read I have no idea what I
was reading I just needed a moment to
collect myself and come to terms with
the fact that the day I met Oprah
Winfrey she meant me
you